and not make it as annoying as those
cookies we have to accept except cookies
like always like
you know there's like always like a
slight amount of trepidation when you
click accept cookies like i feel as
though there's like perhaps like a like
a very tiny chance that it'll open a
portal to hell or something like that
that's exactly how i feel why why do
they why do they keep wanting to accept
that what do they want with this cookie
like somebody got upset with accepting
cookies or something somewhere
who cares like
it's so annoying to keep accepting all
these cookies to me this is just
a great accent yes you can have my damn
cookie i don't care whatever
you heard it from me on first he accepts
all your damn cookies yeah
and start asking me
annoying
yeah it's a it's
one example of um
implementation of a good idea done
really horribly yeah it's somebody was
like there's some good intentions of
like
privacy or whatever but now everyone's
just has to accept cookies and it's not
you know you have billions of people who
have to keep clicking except cookie it's
super annoying
then we just accept the damn cookie it's
fine
you